[Music]
i fell in love
with running track and field when i was
13 during my freshman year of high
school
running became my answer my identity my
anesthesia
when things at home were tough i ran
when school stressed me out i ran
i loved lacing up my shoes my track
spikes were super fly
all white a zipper that covered the
laces which i thought made me more
aerodynamic
and dusted with a neon green saucony
logo
when i wanted to feel free i laced up
those bad boys
and i ran and i ran and i ran
turns out i didn't just have a love for
running
i had a gift for it too
i arrived at stanford with a plan to
walk onto the track team and run my
favorite event
the 400. but my speed caught the eye of
stanford's rugby team which catapulted
me into the world of division 1
athletics
rugby was running but now with kicking
catching
passing and friends as a 17 year old
undergraduate freshman
i competed in my first national
championship
sounds pretty surreal for a girl from
sacramento who just started running to
feel free
i wish i could tell you that that love
never faded
and that sports love me back but i can't
i'm here to tell the truth i'm here to
break silence
i'm here to call out high school and
college sports programs
from coaches to athletic directors from
bystanders to fans
for two often valuing athletes for their
statistics
without any regard for their physical
and psychological
well-being i'm asking you to listen to
my story
to my friend zach's story and to so many
other stories
i'm asking you to sit with the
discomfort of learning the price
that so many athletes pay for your
entertainment
the physical demands of a decade of
competitive sports were enough to break
me
i was 16 when i stopped having periods i
was assured that all was well
and they would return when i stopped
running and gained weight
and then the injury started playing
through them was
normal and expected i played rugby with
a broken hand
i played with frequent shoulder
dislocations
by the time our game schedule allowed
for surgery
my shoulder popped out of its socket
with every sneeze
facial fractures concern for a detached
retina more ankle sprains than i can
count
season ending concussion i could go on
and yet the psychological suffering was
more dizzying
i lost what felt like my soul identity
and became
unhealthily conscious of the foods i put
in my body
but one story hurts more than any other
during my junior year of college i lost
one of the most important people in my
life
grandma fry grandma fry was my great
grandmother and she was the only
grandparent that i ever knew
this was and still is the biggest loss
i have experienced about a week into my
departure to attend her funeral
matt my coach called to ask when i was
returning
he said that he could excuse miss
practices up to this point
but if i expected to start it was time
to come back
it was okay if i wasn't ready but if i
wanted to keep my spot as a starter
it was time to return it may sound like
matt was giving me a choice
but he knew that i idolized him he knew
that this 20 year old still had dreams
of making the national team
he wasn't giving me a choice he gave me
an ultimatum
i don't fully blame him coaches are not
paid to prioritize us
as students as people or as
post-collegiate professionals
we are assets and they are compensated
for winning
but try to imagine what it was like for
this 20 year old
me to be akin to a racehorse
propped up by medals posters with my
face plastered in gyms around campus and
on t-shirts
but unworthy of understanding compassion
and healing
if it costs matt the team or the system
anything even just a little more time
i'm ashamed to admit that i returned i
walked away from my family
in the midst of our shared grief to play
in a single season
game that didn't actually matter
it took me years to fully understand the
impact of that decision
on me and my family
but this isn't just about me so let me
tell you a story about my friend zach
who recently passed away
zach was a guy in college who everyone
wanted to be around he was tall
funny a baseball and football player
and a great dancer at parties i'd see
him whip out these insane dance moves
drawing everyone's eyes towards him
meanwhile
i would awkwardly sway nearby hoping
that no one could tell
how little rhythm i truly had
on campus on film in stats and on the
surface
zach was someone who seemingly had it
all over time however i saw him
transform from this
phenomenal carefree star athlete who
turned pro
to one who was comfortable vocalizing
elements of his story that broke from
this
perfect facade that he showed a perfect
facade that many of us showed
about a year before his death zack
shared in an interview how devastating
it was to medically retire from one too
many concussions
how he suffered through an identity
crisis while simultaneously shouldering
lyme disease mental health issues and
family trauma
in this interview zack admitted that he
didn't even like sports
he died of an accidental drug overdose
at 26.
i don't want to speculate on the
circumstances surrounding his death
and only zach truly knows what he was
going through
but i often wonder how sports played a
role
why he felt pressure to play a game he
didn't enjoy
and how my friend a lovely guy lost his
life
so early zach started to remove his mask
and in the process inspired me to take
off my own
but this isn't just about me and zack
it is so much bigger
it's been five years since i retired my
last pair of cleats
five years since i began to wrestle with
the physical
and emotional damage that a decade of
competitive sports
imprinted on me imprinted on us
so today is the first day that i
publicly break my silence surrounding my
experience
today i'm calling out a culture that
left me like so many athletes to
shoulder
the lifetime costs of these injuries
at best i have three periods a year and
i still don't know why
will i ever be able to have children
will i ever have a normal relationship
with my body
was any of this worth it
i feel really sad
and really angry
why didn't anyone protect me
why didn't anyone protect us
things need to change
that starts with athletes breaking their
silence
more importantly it starts with you
listening
just listen don't ask us to fix the
problem
sit with the heaviness the discomfort
center the athletes who've silently
carried it for so long
i'm scared that if you don't we walk out
of this room
and the same thing will happen to the
next 13 year old girl
who is falling in love with her track
spikes as we speak
i'm asking you to make space for us
to break this silence